let's talk about it what are your
thoughts on Peter being the next
Bachelor
here we go be honest Rachel I'm gonna do
a compliment sandwich
I think Peter seems like a very nice guy
he seems lovely this is absolutely
nothing against him but how many peers
have we seen before what season are we
on mm-hmm
24 so we've seen 24 Peters okay I'm
bored okay is nothing personal against
him I'm sure it'll turn out to be a
great season but for the first time I
was very confident that we were going to
see our first black bachelor and so if
no one else is gonna speak on it then I
guess it's my duty to say it okay well
first black bachelor a lot of people
thought it was gonna be Mike Johnson you
know people were rooting for him what is
your message to fans who might feel
disappointed right now from the news I I
mean I want to be hopeful but when you
have a contestant like Mike and Mike
Johnson and who seems to check all the
boxes how is he not the bachelor I don't
understand what I will say is I am sure
they have some reason for not picking
him and I'm going to trust in that but
at the same time the system isn't
working and giving us a bachelor who's a
person of color so we need to change the
system something has to be done break
the rules step outside the box give the
people what they want if they want
well speaking of that we now know who
the contestants are right so how do you
feel about you know then being received
when it comes to diversity because it's
it's a little color in there but not as
much once again yeah I mean when you
look at who the bachelor is the bachelor
is in charge of saying what they're
interested in okay they're not okay some
people don't know that they do ask you
so I mean you've seen some of the girls
that Peters dated it came out before his
girlfriend was in the news from the past
before Hannah so you know what his type
is at this point and so I expect girls
they're a bit more like a Jana than they
do like me right or someone else of
color very valid points there so just
let's get back to Peter you know we know
your feelings towards him but do you
think other than the whole race factor
or diversity factor do you think he has
what it takes to fill these bachelor
shoes yeah I mean Peter what we saw with
Peter on Hannah season is that he was
very open and then when you saw his
family you saw they were so loved
and they want him to find love and he's
a person who gives his all in
relationships that's the take that I got
so I'm very excited that you know he'll
he'll be open and part of being The
Bachelor is getting other people to open
up about their relationships and I think
that he'll be really good at that okay
so do you have any advice for him any
final words what I will say is ignore
the noise including the noise that I'm
giving I'm she's gonna be a fantastic
Bachelor people just need to get over
the fact that we thought something was
gonna happen that didn't happen well
once he ignores all that just be
yourself be open to love and you can't
lose that's true from the married woman
herself okay take note thank you so much
Rachel for your insight one more break
chill on your TV make sure you catch
MTV's ghost it love gone missing
Tuesdays at 9:00 8:00 central
[Music]